"SUNDAY MORNING FEATURE".
♪.
MARIA: FIRST UP THIS MORNING
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT TOOK
UP ON A BLACK HAWK HELICOPTER
RIGHT ABOVE TEXAS TO VIEW THE
1200 PLUS MILES OF THE TEXAS
BORDER BEING BREACHED EVERYTHING
ALL DAY, SMUGGLERS AND CRIMINAL
CARTELS ARE THE BIGGEST WINNERS,
TRANSPORTING 2000 PEOPLE EVERY
24 HOURS IN RAFTS AND BOATS AND
HELPING SOME THROUGH GAPS, MOST
OF THE PEOPLE COMING AND WANT TO
BE APPREHENDED SO THEY CAN GET
PROCESSED AND ASSIMILATE INTO
AMERICA, BUT THERE IS ANOTHER
GROUP THAT ARE CRIMINALS THAT
GOT AWAY AND ENDED UP IN THE
INTERIOR OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE GOVERNOR ALONG WITH THE HEAD
OF THE NATIONAL GUARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
WALKED ME THROUGH ALL MY WE
TOURED FROM ABOVE.
>> THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
CROSSED THE BORDER THAT WANT TO
GET APPREHENDED SO THEY CAN GET
PROCESSED IN A SIMULATE, IT’S A
PEOPLE THAT NEED A REST THAT
DON’T WANT TO BE CAUGHT, THEY
ARE KNOWN CRIMINALS AND THEY
WOULD WIND UP BACK IN JAIL.
THE DONNA FACILITY, THERE IS
ALMOST TWO DIFFERENT SECTIONS,
ONE OF THESE THAT ARE NEAR TO US
RIGHT NOW, THEY WERE NOT THERE
TWO MONTHS AGO, THAT CAME HERE
TWO MONTHS AGO, THAT WAS JUST
DIRT THEN YOU HAVE THE OTHER
WHITE TENTS ON THE OTHER SIDE
AND THEY WERE THERE WHEN I FIRST
CAME, YOU CAN TELL THEY’RE ALL
RELATIVELY NEW.
THE ACTION PICKS UP AT NIGHT,
THE STUNNING THING FOR ME IS
THAT IT USED TO BE MOST OF THE
ILLEGAL CROSSING OF THE BORDER
WOULD OCCUR AT NIGHTTIME.
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION IT
OCCURS IN HIGH-VOLUME DURING THE
DAYTIME.
MARIA: HAVE YOU SPOKEN WITH THE
PRESIDENT, THE VICE PRESIDENT,
DO THEY REACH OUT TO GET AN
UPDATE ON THINGS?
>> NO, NO.
VERY DIFFERENT FROM THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION.
SO THIS PART RIGHT HERE THAT WAS
THE WALL CONSTRUCTION, YOU SEE
THE EQUIPMENT, THIS IS THE WALL
UNDER CONSTRUCTION AND THEY JUST
STOPPED, YOU CAN SEE RIGHT
APPEAR THEY PICKED IT BACK UP,
THEY JUST DIDN’T CONNECT THE TWO
LOCATIONS.
MARIA: IT WAS ALL PAID FOR.
>> IT WAS ALL PAID FOR.
THE TEXAS BORDER WITH MEXICO IS
ABOUT 1250 MILES INTO BE PRECISE
I WANT TO SAY 1264.
YOU CAN GOOGLE IT.
BUT IF IT WAS STRAIGHT-LINE IN
ARIZONA, IT WOULD BE ONE THING,
THIS IS BARBARA DIFFICULT TO
PATROL AND PROTECT.
MARIA: IS ALL OF MEXICO RUN BY
THE CARTELS OR JUST THE BORDER?
>> UNFORTUNATELY IT’S
SEMI-CORRUPT THROUGHOUT MEXICO
AND THEY UNDERMINE EVERYWHERE
AND THERE’S NO PLACE YOU CAN GET
AWAY FROM THE CARTELS RIGHT NOW,
IT’S A SECURITY THREAT TO THEM.
MARIA: HITS THE CRISIS BIKED
AFTER JANUARY 20 OF THIS YEAR,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IMPRESSED VICE P
HARRIS HAVE NOT VISITED THE
BORDER AND THEY HAVE NOT HEARD
FROM THEM.
AFTER OUR TOUR GREG ABBOTT SAT
DOWN WITH ME FOR THIS EXQUISITE
INTERVIEW.
>> FIRST ABOUT THE PRESIDENT NOT
MENTIONING THE BORDER IN HIS
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS, I
THINK IT SHOWS THAT HE DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT THE BORDER AND THEY
DO NOT WANT TO RESOLVE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BORDER.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THIS, THE
FIRST 100 DAYS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN GREAT
FOR THE CARTELS, THE GANGS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS WHO HAD BEEN
EXPLOITING THE BORDER.
BECAUSE, WHAT HAPPENS, YOU HAD
ALL THESE YOUNG MIGRANTS SEARCH
THE BORDER IN THE BORDER PATROL
OFFICERS ARE OCCUPIED IN DEALING
WITH THOSE WHO ARE SURGED IN AND
THAT IS WHEN THE CARTELS AND
GANG MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO USE THE
OPEN SPACES TO SNEAKER CROSSED
HIGH-VALUE PEOPLE SUCH AS
TERRORIST, SUCH AS PEOPLE WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS AS WELL AS
FENTANYL, THE DRUGS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT, THAT’S EXACTLY WHY WE
HAVE ALL THE PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS DOWN HERE BECAUSE WE
ARE WORKING FOR TEXAS TO DEPLOY
RESOURCES TO SECURE THE BORDER.
MARIA: WHAT KIND OF COST DOES
THIS REPRESENT FOR THE STATE OF
TEXAS, WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE COST.
>> AND DOES NOT COME FREE, OUR
STATE LEGISLATURE, THEY ALLOCATE
$800 MILLION EVERY TWO YEARS FOR
THE STATE TO PAY FOR THIS, THIS
YEAR BECAUSE OF THE EXTENDED
TIME WILL HAVE THE NATIONAL
GUARD ON THE BORDER IT WILL
CLEARLY EXCEED A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE STATE TO SECURE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HERE’S OUR GOAL, WERE PAYING FOR
THIS BUT I WANT TO HAVE TEXAS
SECURE THE BORDER AND HAVE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION PAY FOR IT.
MARIA: WERE GONNA TALK WITH AG
PAXTON LATER ON IN THE SHOW, HE
MADE A POINT SAYING TEXAS AS A
LAUNCHPAD BUT ONCE THEY COME IN
THROUGH TEXAS, ILLEGALS ARE
GOING ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
DRUGS ARE GOING INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY, TELL ME
ABOUT THAT, ONE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS TOLD ME THE NUMBERS FOR
FENTANYL AROUND 5000%
YEAR-OVER-YEAR, HEROIN OF 4000%
IN TERMS OF DRUGS SEIZED.
>> YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY AND MIDWESTERN PART IN
THE NORTHERN PART, THEY THINK
THAT’S A BORDER ISSUE, THE
BORDER COMES TO THEM EVERY
SINGLE DAY BECAUSE AS PEOPLE
CROSS THE BORDER THEY TAKE THE
GANG MEMBERS THAT WILL EXPORT
THE DRUGS TO CHICAGO TO NEW YORK
TO NORTH AND SOUTH CAROLINA EVEN
UP TO WASHINGTON STATE OR OTHER
PLACES LIKE THAT, EVERY STATE IS
AFFECTED OTHER PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY,
THAT’S EXACTLY WHY ALL OF US
NEED TO JOIN TOGETHER IN THIS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE WERE
SECURING IT SO WERE STOPPING THE
DRUG TRAFFICKERS IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IS ONE OF THE VICIOUS AND
SERIOUS CRIMES THAT TAKE THE
PLACE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT’S THE WAY PEOPLE COME ACROSS
THE BOARD OF IS THROUGH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THOSE CONTINUING
THE UNITED STATES AS THEY
EXPLOIT PEOPLE AND WHERE THEY
WOULD SEND THEM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
MARIA: THE OTHER THING THAT
STRUCK ME, ONCE THEY RELEASED
AFTER THEY GET PROCESSED, THEY
GET LEGAL STATUS.
>> IT SHOWS THE PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S APPROACH TO
THIS WHERE THEY’RE SUPPOSED TO
DETAIN THEM, DISLIKE THEM, TO
ACQUIRE THAT THEY SHOW UP FOR
COURT HEARING AND THEY’VE
ABANDONED THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING CITATIONS AND
REQUIRING APPEARANCE AT THE
COURTS TO SHOW UP, THAT DOES
MEAN ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS GET
ACROSS THE BORDER AND YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT TO DO AND
OF COURSE THAT MEANS IT’S AN
ABANDONMENT IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION LAWS PASSED BY THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
MARIA: WHY IS THE BITE IN A
ADMINISTRATION ALLOWING THIS.
>> WHAT YOU’RE ASKING IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION IN THE
UNITED STATES, TOO MANY PEOPLE
ARE NOT ASKING, NONE OF THE
JOURNALIST AND NOT ENOUGH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE ASKING
WHY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING NOTHING TO STOP THIS FROM
HAPPENING AND NOT EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGING WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE GOING TO BE TO
whose resumes on Indeed
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
YOU MENTIONED ONE THING ABOUT
THE COST THE COST WE ARE
INCURRING TO SECURING THE BORDER
BUT WE DID TALK ABOUT THE
HEALTHCARE COST, EDUCATION COST,
LAW ENFORCEMENT COST, ALL THESE
OTHER COSTS THAT WILL BE NOT
JUST PAYCHECKS BUT THESE OTHER
STATES, THE GANGS, THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS EVENTUALLY GO TO.
MARIA: IT SEEMED LIKE THE
CARTELS ARE REALLY WINNING AND
MAKING BIG MONEY, SOMEONE TOLD
ME THIS WEEK THAT THEY’RE MAKING
$400 MILLION MONTHLY.
THE NUMBERS BECAUSE ARE CHARGING
$4000 AHEAD, THEY’RE TAKING 2000
PEOPLE A DAY INTO AMERICA,
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU COME FROM
THE NUMBERS ARE HIGHER, ONE
GUARD TOLD ME THEY APPREHENDED A
FROM CHINA IN THE GROUP FROM
CHINA TOLD THEM THAT THEY PAID
$50000 AHEAD AND BY THE WAY
THESE WERE SCIENTISTS AND
DOCTORS AND ENGINEERS FROM CHINA
CHINA, YOU HAVE TO ASK WHY THE
CCP IS SENDING THESE PEOPLE TO
THE BORDER, OBVIOUSLY THEY DON’T
WANT TO BE NOTICED, WHAT ARE
THEY DOING WHEN THEY GET HERE.
>> AS BINOCHE, THEIR GAME THIS
SHOWS THE DANGER OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NOT TWEET
ANYTHING.
WE NEED TO DEBUNK IF THERE IS
ANYBODY OUT THERE THAT THINKS
THESE ARE PEOPLE COMING FROM
MEXICO OR CENTRAL AMERICA COMING
HERE TO ENGAGE IN AGRICULTURE,
THEY’RE FORGETTING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE FROM CHINA, FROM IRAN
EET I WORK.
>> SHE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
PLANTING TREES, I CAN’T REMEMBER
WHAT THEY’RE PLANNING ON DOING
BUT LET’S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY’RE NOT DOING THEY’RE NOT
COMING DOWN HERE TO THE BORDER
THEY HAD 100 DAYS IN OFFICE
RIGHT NOW, THIS IS THE BIGGEST
CRISIS THEY’RE DEALING WITH AND
THEY FAILED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CRISIS, THEY WILL EVEN COME DOWN
HERE TO ADDRESS IT, UNTIL THEY
COME DOWN HERE AND SEE WHAT’S
GOING ON ON THE GROUND AND SEE
HOW POOR IS THE BORDER ACTUALLY
IS SEE HIS COMING ACROSS IS NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND
THEY NEED TO STEP UP AND ADDRESS
IT.
MARIA: THE ROOT CAUSES, SHE SAID
THE ROOT CAUSES POVERTY, WHAT
ABOUT THE ROOT CAUSE OF WHY THEY
DECIDED NOW.
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP WE SEEN
APPREHENSION THAT A 45 YEAR LOW.
>> THE ROOT CAUSE IS A LACK OF
BORDER SECURITY.
AS A SECURE THE BORDER.
LET’S STEP BACK READ MOST
AMERICANS PUT MYSELF IN THIS
CLASS, MOST AMERICANS BELIEVE IN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND IF YOU
BELIEVE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION YOU
NEED TO SUPPORT ENFORCING THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION LAWS IN THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ABANDONING.
MARIA: ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION WE
ISSUED 1 MILLION GREEN CARDS
EVERY YEAR, COMING UP MORE OF MY
Not today,
dry eye.
WE CONTINUE WITH OUR EXCLUSIVE
COVERAGE THE STATE OF TEXAS SUED
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
GOVERNOR ABBOTT DEMAND
ADMINISTRATION SHUT DOWN ONE
FACILITY IN SAN ANTONIO BECAUSE
OF ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE
INCLUDING SEXUAL ASSAULT TAKING
PLACE THERE.
>> MULTIPLE CONCERNS I HAD AT
THE FACILITY AND OTHER
FACILITIES WE HAD IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS, THERE WERE ALLEGATIONS
WITH TWO STATE AGENCIES IN
TEXAS, SEXUAL ASSAULTS VERY GOOD
TEST THESE ARE NOT NEW, YOU NEED
UNDERSTAND THIS IS NOT A ONE
TYPE OF ALLEGATION, ALLEGATIONS
LIKE THIS HAVE OCCURRED OVER THE
YEARS AND ONE REASON THEY OCCUR
BECAUSE YOU HAVE AN INADEQUATE
NUMBER OF STAFF OVERSEEING IT,
FROM WHAT I OBSERVED MYSELF FROM
GOING INTO THE FACILITY I SELL
NO LAW ENFORCEMENT, NO SECURITY
WHATSOEVER INSIDE OR OUTSIDE THE
FACILITY, I’VE SEEN THESE
FACILITIES ACROSS THE ENTIRE
BORDER REGION AND NONE OF THEM
HAVE I SEEN ANY TYPE OF SECURITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ESCAPE OR ENGAGE
IN OTHER DANGER PEOPLE INSIDE OR
OUTSIDE THE FACILITY.
MARIA: THE BROADER AGENDA, THE
LACK OF POLICY, WHAT HAS BEEN A
RADICAL AGENDA, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE PUSHING H.R.1, THEY’RE
PUSHING TO GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER, THEY WANT TO PACK
THE SUPREME COURT, PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAID HE’S GONNA PUT UP
COMMISSION TOGETHER, WHAT ARE
YOU SEEING FROM YOUR STANDPOINT
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
TERMS OF TAKING POWER AWAY FROM
THE STATE.
>> YOU SAID IT PERFECTLY, WHEN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO DO IS REDESIGN AMERICA IN A
WAY THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE
CONSTITUTION, THE UNITED STATES
WAS DESIGNED TO EACH STATE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE ITS OWN DESIGN,
TEXAS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
WHY WE NEED TO ABSTAIN SPEAK
DIFFERENT, TEXAS RANKS NUMBER
ONE OF EVERY ECONOMIC CATEGORY.
MARIA: HAVE YOU SEEN A BIG
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE MOVING TO
TEXAS.
>> WE HAVE NO IDEA, ONE THING
THAT HAPPENED IN THE CENSUS
TEXAS ADDED MORE PEOPLE IN THE
DECADE OVER ANY OTHER STATE,
PEOPLE ARE MOVING HERE RIGHT AND
LEFT, HOWEVER, THIS PAST YEAR
THE YEAR OF COVID REALLY
ACCELERATED ALL OF THAT.
MARIA: TELL ME ABOUT THE
LAWSUIT, TEXAS HAS BEEN SUING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS, NUMBER OF
STATES FOR THE XL PIPELINE AND
THIS IS SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT
TO YOU IN A REAL STORY FOR TEXAS
IN THE COUOUNTRY.
>> THE XL PIPELINE IS A SUBSET
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT
IS TO CRACK DOWN ON FOSSIL
FUELS, LET ME TELL YOU HE IS
HURTING IN THE POLLS BECAUSE OF
THAT IN ONE REASON WHY PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HIS REELECTION
CAMPAIGN DID SO WELL IN THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY.
MARIA: WHAT ABOUT THE SENSES, I
HAVE TWO MORE ITEMS, SENSES AND
THE COVID, WHAT’S HAPPENING HERE
IN TEXAS BECAUSE YOU’RE OPEN FOR
BUSINESS, WE SAW CHANGES IN THE
SENSES AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE
LOOKING AT INVESTIGATING THIS,
DID YOU LOSE A CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT, WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
CONSENSUS NUMBERS.
>> I THINK OF INVESTIGATION DOES
NEED TO BE DONE, THEY NEED TO DO
IT VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE THE
TIMECLOCK IS SHORT, IF YOU LOOK
AT ALL THE NUMBERS OF MANY RED
STATES, AN INITIAL ASSESSMENT OF
THE NUMBERS OF WHAT THE
POPULATION GROUP WAS WAS REDUCED
BY THE FINAL NUMBERS.
ANOTHER BLUE STATES, THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE LOSING POPULATION
NOT LOSING AS MUCH AS
PROGNOSTICATOR.
THERE IS SOMETHING FISHY ABOUT
THE FINAL CENSUS RESULTS, IT’S
RIGHT THERE WILL BE AN
INVESTIGATION AND LITIGATION TO
CLARIFY WHAT’S GOING ON, WHO
CHANGE THE NUMBERS, WHY DID THEY
CHANGE IT, WASN’T A VALID